Microsoft is looking to get back on top
of the games industry in 2020 with the
Xbox Series X game pass in Project X
cloud however it's going to take a great
lineup of exclusives to win most folks
over in 2020 so join us as we dive into
the biggest Xbox Series X and Xbox one
console exclusives coming this year
Orion the will of wisps is set to
release March 11th and is the sequel to
2015's blind forest a charming fable
that earned a 9 out of 10 score on
GameSpot will of wisps looks to bring
back the precise platforming and escape
sequences of the previous game while
exploring more of its vibrant world and
emotional storytelling bleeding-edge
arrives March 24th and is a third-person
4v4 hero melee action game from the
makers of hell blade from what we've
seen so far it's shaping up to have an
art style reminiscent of overwatch Devil
May Cry style combat and vehicles for
quick map transitioning Crusader Kings 3
comes from a series of strategy games
focus on feudal powers during the Middle
Ages it has a map stretching from Spain
to India and Scandinavia to Central
Africa while setting up your dynasty you
can employ a variety of deceptive
schemes including murder seduction and
blackmail if you enjoy beating up
peasants levying taxes and producing
heirs Crusader Kings 3 is releasing
sometime in 2020 coming between April
and June this year grounded is a co-op
survival game that seems inspired by
Honey I Shrunk the Kids in that it
shares a very similar premise developed
by Obsidian Entertainment a studio known
for RPGs like the outer worlds and Star
Wars Knights of the Old Republic - the
game challenges you to cook food find
water construct bases and craft weapons
to survive its towering threats coming
sometime between October and December
details have been limited about
Microsoft's Halo Infinite the story
trailer showed Master Chief stranded but
alive
Cortana still gone and a shattered halo
ring lost in some war by humans aside
from these slim narrative details we do
know that infinite also runs on the new
slipspace
engine which powered the debut cinematic
trailer we also know that it will have
an upcoming beta allowing players to get
their hands on the game ahead of launch
it's currently one
the few games confirmed to be released
on Xbox series of X it has been far too
long since flight sim fans used their
thrust master joysticks to play a brand
new Microsoft Flight Simulator after all
the last entry came out in 2006 bah we
don't know exactly when the new game
will take flight this year we do know
that it will include a wide variety of
aircraft to fly from single seaters to
commercial jets it'll also include
up-to-date landscapes based on satellite
images rendered in 4k resolution session
is a skating simulator that's looking to
reinvigorate the fan-favorite genre with
a stick per foot skating system in depth
gameplay footage editing and sharing
functionality and a faithfulness to
recreating many of the world's most
iconic skate parks for you to explore
and pull off tricks it went into early
access on Steam in late 2019 but ran
into delays transitioning to Xbox one
we're not exactly sure how much longer
fans of the game will have to wait
but it's confirmed to fully launch for
the platform sometime this year tell me
why is a narrative adventure game from
the studio that made life is strange it
focuses on a set of twins returning to
Alaska to investigate childhood trauma
exploring the twins as different
interpretations of events crossed their
lives up to that point
tell me wise story will unravel across
three chapters confirmed to release mid
2020
are the Xbox exclusive games coming in
2020 that we know about so far but we're
sure there are more announcements to
come in the months ahead
until then which of these games is your
most anticipated let us know in the
comments below and for all things
related to next-gen consoles
stick to GameSpot
[Music]
you
[Music]